oh afghanistan's former president assaf
ghani has released a statement
explaining why he left kabul in
mid-august zhani says it was the only
way to ensure peace in the capital but
he denies reports claiming that he fled
kabul with millions of dollars ghani
says he is open to an official audit or
even a financial investigation monitored
by the um
former president who served between 2014
and 2021 says he regrets his term ended
without stability and prosperity
has apologized to all afghans for his
failure he's been granted political
asylum in the united arab emirates
with the taliban in control the u.s has
frozen billions of dollars in bank
reserves that could be used for aid
other major donors like the world bank
and the imf have also halted aid they've
said they're waiting to see what kind of
leadership the taliban demonstrates
before releasing funds over the last 20
years afghanistan has relied heavily on
foreign aid the biggest donor the u.s
poured about 36 billion dollars into the
economy for education and infrastructure
projects humanitarian aid accounted for
another four billion but international
support began to decline well before the
taliban took over in 2009 it accounted
for 100 percent of the country's gdp but
a decade later it was less than half
that
afghanistan's domestically driven
economy is fragile growth in the private
sector has been limited and about 40
percent of its workforce lives off of
farming and agriculture
alofti rahimi is head of research at
buruni institute and assistant professor
of economics at american university of
afghanistan and joins us uh via skype
now uh from london thanks very much for
being with us so um we're just given
kind of a breakdown there in in that uh
graphic of of the distribution of aid
and and
the fact that the u.s
uh donates a large portion of it but if
we can expand on that a little bit and i
want to ask you
how how is the total amount of aid and
the makeup of that where it goes how has
that changed uh over the years over the
last 20 years
well thank you hussein for having me um
aid has definitely changed
you could say 2012 was an inflection
point uh in terms of how aid was being
dispersed and given to afghanistan
um usually there is an uh
rolling fortier uh routine uh eighth
conference that used to happen between
the previous african government and its
international partners where pledges
used to happen and
on average
about
4 billion of development aid was being
given to afghanistan up until 2016
and 2012 marks an inflection point
because there was a separation between
military aid and development aid and
then also started the transition of
security forces that declined aid to
afghanistan as well at that point
um so um you could you could say from a
very macro perspective
that up until 2016 there is about
6 billion us dollars of
aid given to the government from 2001
and then the military aid was separated
that was about 5 to 6 billion as well
since 2016 that has declined um two to
three to three to four billion dollars
on each of these categories
uh and domestic revenue has been very
low um and not sufficient to actually uh
finance the expenditures of a government
of that size
so it had different periods and
different factors involved in terms of
its uh decline as well
basic government expenditures were being
funded through aid uh something around
so
100 of development budget of the
government was
um being was being funded through aid up
until very recently like 2019
or 20
then
the recurrent budget of the government
that salaries mostly uh and other bills
that the government use usually pays
was also being funded
between 40 to 50 of it was being funded
up until very recent days of that
government through aid so it has been an
integral part of uh government
um
the previous government up until now all
right if i could ask you as well though
um
just we mentioned there at the top how
the world bank and and the imf are
holding aid uh for now in the united
states as well because they want to see
what what this taliban government is
going to look like um but we've seen the
effects of that uh how it's affecting
africans afghans particularly in
hospitals is that the right thing to be
doing to be somewhat say weaponizing aid
like this
um let me backtrack that's not i think
absolutely um
that is not a very correct picture of
putting it's it econo the economy was
declining way before the taliban took
over uh several years of conflict uh
siege to different cities
had its impact it displaced a lot of
afghans uh disrupted flow of business
and business as usual in all of these
provinces if you guys remember a couple
of months ago tachar province was under
siege hondus province all the front
lines uh when when the conflict was at
its peak for the past six months that
has
impacted life in afghanistan beyond
repair so
um halting aid
um just uh because of the takeover that
happened on the 14th of august
hasn't caused these issues and i think
humanitarian aid is needed and it should
be resumed um the us
and these international development
agencies like the imf and the world bank
has their own concerns and legat legal
issues okay in terms of holding back i
think the world bank is currently
working with with the current government
uh off the taliban on some health
projects
um even on the 25th of august there was
a license issued by the um
by the u.s treasury
allowing humanitarian aid to flow into
it
we've got to leave it we've got to leave
it there appreciate you uh appreciate
you talking to us lufti rahimi in kabul
thanks and yeah thanks for being with us
thank you